[Musique]
non le débat sur france 24 que se
passe-t-il sur le front ukrainien les
forces armées ukrainiennes reconquiert
les villes du nord-est du pays à forte
cadence depuis début septembre plus de
3000 kilomètres carrés sont revenus sous
contre l'ukrainien c'est en tout cas ce
qu'a déclaré le commandant en chef de
l'armée ukrainienne valérie elsa
lunghini is you may été libéré en 24
heures la contre-offensive menée dans le
nord a permis de récupérer 20 localités
dans la région de kharkiv la russie a
affirmé avoir bombardé ces zones ce
matin alors est-ce un tournant dans la
guerre en ukraine où en est-on où en est
le rapport de force quelle est la
réponse des russes poutine est il
fragilisé on en débat avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
oksana mitrofanova bonsoir vous êtes
politologue enseignante chercheuse à
l'inalco à bienvenue à vous dans le
débat et lenovo le chine est avec nous
bonsoir lna journaliste à france 24
spécialiste de la russie puis notre
ancienne correspondante à moscou à côté
de vous claude blanchemaison bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous un ancien
ambassadeur en russie c'était entre 2000
et 2003 hauteur de poutine sécher
temporis édition et c'est vivre avec
poutine le titre de votre livre nous
avons aussi en tout cas il va nous
rejoindre s'il n'est pas encore là mais
je le vois il est là gulliver craag
notre correspondant à france 22 france24
donc qui est avec nous à kiev bonsoir
gulliver et on attend donc l'amiral
alain kohl dolphy ancien chef on sait
major
général des armées qui devraient nous
rejoindre on va démarrer tout de suite
avant cette discussion on va faire un
point sur le terrain d'avoir de cette
fameuse contre-offensive ukrainienne
avec florent redoux
c'est une tendance qui se confirme au
200e jour du conflit l'armée ukrainienne
continuent de gagner du terrain au
nord-est près de rare qu'yves ou sa
contre offensive a pris de court les
soldats russes eux qui s'attendait
davantage à être attaqué sur le front
sud au petit fca donc mais aussi bas la
clia coupe inc et yum dont la prise a
été annoncée dimanche soir par le
président et lenski izon les
représailles russes n'ont pas tardé avec
selon kiev le bombardement du réseau
électrique de la ville des frappes
également constaté à pau croft plus au
sud
basé à washington l'institut pour
l'étude de la guerre là sur kiev a
repris en cinq jours plus de territoire
que les russes n'en n'ont conquis depuis
avril en tout plus de 3000 kilomètres
carrés serait revenue sous son contrôle
depuis début septembre
des pertes que le ministère russe de la
défense a lui même reconnu dans son
briefing quotidien carte à l'appui
une contre-offensive ukrainienne
impossible sans le soutien des
occidentaux et de leurs armes
capable de frapper aussi bien les
premières lignes russes que celle plus
éloignés servant au ravitaillement
le chef de la diplomatie à kiev a
d'ailleurs appelé une nouvelle fois ses
alliés à poursuivre ses livraisons
d'armes alors que petit à petit le
drapeau ukrainien fait son retour sur
les bâtiments officiels comme ici dans
la région de rares kif
et je vous propose d'écouter tout de
suite des réactions
ou ma ville libérée
aujourd'hui dans la matinée deux
véhicules sont arrivés dans la rue où
nous vivons nous sommes allés à leur
rencontre les larmes aux yeux nous les
attendus on ne pouvait pas imaginer
qu'il viendrait de façon aussi attendus
on les attend depuis près de six mois et
on est tellement heureux
les russes ont commencé à s'échapper
dans la soirée non en fait à 1h30 du
matin le pilonnage a commencé et ils ont
mis le feu aux endroits où ils étaient
couvrir leurs traces c'est ainsi que
nous avons compris qu'ils étaient finis
difficile émotionnellement
c'était difficile dès les premiers jours
parce que l'électricité et l'eau étaient
coupées
il faisait froid il n'y avait rien à
manger
tous les voisins se sont réunis et parce
que nous étions tous ensemble nous avons
survie qu
il y avait des russes et ce matin des
ukrainiens
dire que je suis heureux ce n'est pas
suffisant
je n'ai pas de mots pour m'exprimer mois
et gulliver gulliver craag à kiev on
vient d'entendre donc ses habitants
disent youm cette ville qui a et ont été
libérés par avec cette contre-offensive
ukrainienne dans le nom elle paraît
spectaculaire cette contre offensive est
sa tournant
surtout peut-être parce que la ville
d'izu a été prise et les yeux c'était la
place d'armes terrus la base si vous
voulez pour leurs tentatives d'essayer
de prendre le reste d'une base la partie
de la région de donetsk qu'il n'avait
pas réussi à prendre au corps ils
contrôlent encore des endroits juste au
sud est de la région donetsk est presque
la totalité de la région de lougansk
mais attaquer en allant vers le nord
sans pouvoir attaquer simultanément en
allant vers le sud depuis zoom savons
très difficile de la possibilité pour
les russes de continuer leur offensive
leur tentative de reprendre de te
prendre part dont le reste de la région
de donetsk donc c'est peut-être idiot
mme laprise clé dans cette contre
offensive mais les ukrainiens sont même
allés bien au-delà ils ont pris je pense
qu'il y avait très peu de gens en
ukraine qui s'attendaient à ce qu'ils
arrivent aussi rapidement à reprendre
autant de territoires oksana mitrofanov
vous avez été surprise également par
cette contre offensive éclair on dit
cinq jours en cinq jours il aura repris
plus de 20 localités non même 20
localités en 24 heures fait en tout cas
depuis cinq jours ils ont vraiment
poussé très loin ses forces russes
c'était une surprise pour vous d'abord
il faut dire que les citations de change
et moi je préfère vraiment rester
prudente moment un seul hymne aux
communistes de défense réuni kof qui est
vraiment il faut être très très prudent
parce qu on en importe quel moment on
peut avoir un autre contre offensive de
russes donc les ukrainiennes doivent se
préparer à voir le scénario vraiment
différent au point de vue militaire bien
sûr c'est très important le tournant
dans la guerre mais pour l'instant on ne
connaît pas pour l'instant le si le
public était payé par par les ukrainiens
le prix je veux dire le plus cher ce
qu'on a c'est la vie de soldats
ukrainienne deux femmes deux hommes donc
il y à des facteurs différentes ensuite
dès qu'ils ont appris la langue la ville
bien sûr les gens veulent revenir marc
se posent les questions
d'infrastructures pour que les gens
reviennent dans la citation plus ou
moins correct et safe il faut passer par
le processus de déminage mais il faut
ainsi reiki omaha l'électricité il y à
de l'eau il y eut des gaz donc c'est
passé financé pas si évident claude
blanchemaison c'est vrai que est-ce
qu'on est surpris tout de même par on
peut dire cette défaite même de l'armée
russe côté russe caisse vous effacez
prudent comme ça viendrait le 10 mai sur
la vie c'est vrai qu'on a affaire à deux
armées qui sont complètement différente
on a une nation en armes qui défend son
territoire contre un corps
expéditionnaire de deux cent mille
hommes on sait plus très bien combien y
en a pas ce qui est beaucoup de morts et
que la russie n'arrive pas forcément à
recruter pour les remplacer c'est un
corps expéditionnaire est en terrain
étranger au bout du compte même s'il
voit qu'il parle russe et qui savent pas
très bien pourquoi ils sont là donc le
moral effectivement de ce corps
expéditionnaire russe est certainement
au plus bas en plus son type de
commandement est archaïque puisque ce
sont les généraux qui commande les
opérations sur le terrain il n'y a
absolument pas de délégation au chef
opérationnel comme alors que l'armée
ukrainienne se bat avec des techniques
beaucoup plus moderne de mobilité avec
des commandants qui sont responsables
sur le terrain et on voit bien que sont
beaucoup plus nombreux si je comprends
bien sur le terrain les ukrainiens oui
parce que effectivement comme on a dit
pendant très longtemps qu'il y avoir une
contre offensive dans le sud à kherson
les russes ont déplacé des troupes vers
le sud pour protéger naturellement
l'arrière-pays la crimée
personnes c'était important on en
parlera peut-être pas l'heure mais
effectivement il est possible que les
ukrainiens et profiter du fait que les
russes ne s'attendait pas à une attaque
véritablement très offensive à cet
endroit précisément à djoum et sur la
ligne d'approvisionnement qui relie leur
troupe du dodo net à belga belgorod qui
est maintenant contrôlée par les
ukrainiens elena ils ont avoué quelque
part une certaine défaite les russes
depuis justement cette contre offensive
depuis justement cette reprise par les
ukrainiens 10 ou même non non non une
telle communication la fpt la
communication bon alors on a entendu le
général igor konachenkov le porte parole
du ministère russe de la défense par les
deux regroupements c'est à dire qu'on ne
s'est pas retirée on n'a pas reculé on
regroupe un regroupement stratégique en
fait de nos armées ado n'y est que pour
ensuite en gros ce qu'ils disent est en
recule pour mieux sauter c'est
exactement ce qu'il avait dit au moment
si vous en souvenez de la première
défaite en fait de cette grande guerre
de blitzkrieg qui avait voulu mener la
russie en envoyant sa colonne de chars
prendre kiev bon mot ou la prise des
localités autour de kiev a été un échec
malgré sa barbarie et que l'armée russe
a dû se retirer le ministère russe de la
défense disait déjà on va se concentrer
sur le dombass parce que c'est une
priorité donc en fait c'est exactement
la même rhétorique donc il n'y a
absolument aucun aveu d'échec au
contraire par exemple vous titrez
aujourd'hui un tournant dans la guerre
je regardais pas plus tard que tout à
l'heure une émission de la télévision
russe une émission phare de débat là
aussi il citera aussi un tournant dans
la guerre mais eux mettre l'accent sur
les frappes de l'armée russe contre
l'infrastructure stratégique ukrainienne
qui a mis hors tension notamment par
exemple la ville de kharkiv en disant
c'est la russie qui est l offensive
regarder on a redoublé d'intensité parce
que on nous a provoqué alors maintenant
on va tous sortir on va tout donner et
d'ailleurs on se souvient des paroles de
vladimir poutine qui disait nous n'avons
rien commencé encore est donc là
aujourd'hui la russie prétend que et
bien ayant été forcé de mener la grande
offensive contre l'ukraine c'est ce
qu'elle serait en train de faire c'est
ça aujourd'hui la rhétorique près
propagandistes russe oksana mitrofanova
est ce que finalement c'est aussi grâce
aux armes on parle beaucoup de
l'artillerie américaine qui est arrivé
sur place est ce que c'est aussi l'une
des clés des sucs du succès de cette
contre-offensive un bien sûr absolument
parce que si le crâne et resté seul sans
l'aide de ses alliés occidentaux c'est
peut-être ça menait vers l'échec
donc maintenant
par exemple stocks d'armes soviétique
qui a vu l'armée ou craignent ans sa
bouche vers la fin donc il faut la
remplacer vous donc voilà pourquoi le
gouvernement ukrainien insiste comme un
besoin de plus en plus d'armes et là
vraiment différente c'est leur tirelire
et moi aussi se pose la question de
défense en cas rien parce que maintenant
on a déjà reçu et on voit recevoir la
réponse ou la vengeance de rossi et
qu'est ce que c'est cette chance c'est
bien sûr c'est exactement c'est les
fables sur l'infrastructure les frappes
seront deux fois structuré on va couper
l'approvisionnement d'électricité et par
exemple mr départ qui fait déjà annoncé
qu' on ne coupe de l'eau et de
l'électricité à kharkiv qui a passé par
certains moments ça c'est grave mais
pour l'instant on se trouve on était
plus c'est le temps que nous sommes
encore être même tout l'hiver et quand
on doit avoir moins 10 au moins 20 et si
on va couper le chauffage c'est donc
j'ai coupé en fait ce que vous êtes en
train de dire c'est qu'ils sont les
russes qui coupent l'électricité le
chauffeur alors en tout cas je pars de
fera par l'émission c'est le service
français le futur ne pas ce n'est pas
qu'on ne peut dire des coupures mais
quel est le résultat d'efforts tout
simplement à l'heure où se fera par les
missiles les entreprises qui produisent
l'électricité c'est que le plus grave
parce que acheminement faire la cheminée
l'électricité se réparer ce plan semble
qui reparaît l'entreprise qui était
bombardée donc du coup si on ne va pas
garder l'entreprise essentielle
craignant qu'ils produisent
l'électricité et surtout en hiver ce
sera très grave donc voilà pourquoi je
pose les questions aussi d'armes c'est
exactement la défense anti-aérien
pourquoi on a besoin de se défendre sans
terriens aussi pour protéger tout
simplement l'infrastructure pour voir
impossible et est donnée d'électricité
donné du gas donnaient de l'eau oui
c'est un point crucial gulliver gilbert
craag à kiev donc ces armements cette
artillerie qu'ils ont finalement reçu
américaine a été clé dans cette contre
offensive c'est aussi ce qu'on dit à
kiev là on voit oksana mitrofanova qui
dit il faut continuer à livrer même
d'autres armes on n'y aura pas d'armes
allons porter en tout cas oui
c'est
c'est absolument le message articulé par
les dirigeants ukrainiens soit le
ministre de la défense dans l'axé reste
des corps vous le ministère des affaires
étrangères de m coulez pas
répétition il martèle ce message
regardez comment on a montré qu'on sait
utiliser vos armes et qu'on a une bonne
stratégie et on peut gagner 7 vers cette
guerre d'autant plus vite et avec tout
au moins des pertes si vous nous livrez
plus d'un plus rapidement c'est cette
contre offensive a été encore une fois
employée par les ukrainiens pour
justifier leur demande alors allié
occidental de renvoyer fils d'or mais je
pense que l'absolument en raison de dire
que le cren maintenant on va avoir
cruellement besoin je pense de plus de
défense anti aérienne si la stratégie
des russes a vraiment changé pour
commencer à cibler de manière très très
explicites et aytré exprès les
infrastructures civiles de génération
d'électricité etc c'est effectivement
on a un petit problème de song univers
avec vous claude blanche maison on
parlait justement à l'instant également
du sud parce que donc là il ya cette
contre offensive au nord donc et avancer
ses prises sept reprises 10e on voit
bien sur cette carte et puis dans le sud
un lien on sait qu'il ya des combats
aussi extrêmement important donc qu'est
ce qui se passe du côté de carson parce
que là aussi il ya une contre offensive
c'est pratiquement la première dont on
parlait d'ailleurs sur le plateau
l'ukrainienne et est-ce que c'était
effectivement pour faire diversion qu'on
parlait d'abord de contre-offensive à
kherson ukrainiennes ou pas peut-être
qu'il ya eu un effet de diversion parce
que les russes étaient mal informés que
le renseignement russe une fois de plus
à mal fonctionner mais les ukrainiens
ont très clairement l'intention de mener
une contre-offensive aussi à carson et
c'est vrai que les russes à kherson
peuvent assez facilement être en
difficulté puisque c'est le seul endroit
où les troupes russes se trouve sur la
rive droite du dniepr et que bien
entendu
l'armée ukrainienne a fait sauter tous
les ponts et qu'au fur et à mesure où
les russes remplacer pont par des ponts
provisoires militaire et bien les
ukrainiens les font sauter également
c'est un jeu qui se déroule
quotidiennement donc potentiellement
des soldats russes l'armée russe qui se
trouvent autour de kherson sur la rive
droite du nieppe pourrait se trouver
isolées sans pouvoir revenir à l'arrière
sans pouvoir traverser le nieppe et
retrouver les autres troupes d'ailleurs
on dit que les états majors eux ont déjà
franchi le dieppe pour se mettre à
l'abri sur la gauche et les avocats
chine est importante en fait cette cette
zone sud un important pour les russes
aussi un traitement ont parlé au début
de la guerre du fait qu'ils voulaient
rallier la transnistrie par la bande sud
prendre odessa et ces personnes ça a été
la première grande ville capitale
régionale qui a été occupée par les
russes et on voit effectivement ils
veulent depuis plusieurs mois en fait
organiser un référendum sur place pour
donner cette apparence de légitimité qui
est la technologie classique lors d'une
invasion de faire voter sous le
sou
le calibre des fusils les les
populations pour donner l'apparence de
légitimité à cette occupation il
n'arrive pas à organiser ce référendum
justement alors quand bien même qu'ils
ont mis en place déjà les programmes
scolaires qui l'ont déjà remplacer les
manuels qu'ils ont déjà fait venir des
médecins des instituteurs russe dans les
écoles qui sont lancés en distribuer les
passeports etc mise en place les cartes
sim russe etc enfin disons que ils sont
ils ont quasiment installé déjà la
russie à kherson avant l'heure parce que
effectivement ça se situe sur la ligne
de front parce que toutes les
difficultés stratégie qui viennent
d'être d'être d'être énoncé mais c'est
vrai que voilà carson pour la russie
voulait être acquise or elle ne l'est
pas du tout allez-y juste une phrase
presque on pourrait ajouter aussi que
dans le fond la région de kherson c'est
l'arrière pays de la crimée et c'est une
raison supplémentaire pour laquelle la
russie attache beaucoup d'importance
pour assurer l'alimentation en eau douce
de la crimée c'est par là que ça que
cela passe et effectivement dans toute
cette affaire
le le le
la fin de la fin de la position de
poutine c'est de verrouiller la ferc de
la crimée or effectivement le président
s'énerve qui répète assez souvent que il
faudra qu'ils que la queue que le cred
recouvre son intégrité territoriale
il compte y compris la crimée vous avez
amiral à l'école de filles mères jour
d'être avec vous nous avez rejoint alors
justement parlé un petit peu puisque
vous êtes tout de même militaire de ce
plateau est ce que les ukrainiens ont
fait diversion en parle en parlant de
contre-offensive à kherson donc dans le
sud alors que finalement c'est la
kharkiv que ça s'est passé en cinq jours
il aurait repris 20 localités dont
idiome en tout cas alors divergences et
peut-être pas le mot en réalité ils ont
concentré leurs efforts dans la partie
qui l'ont reconquise de façon très
intelligente avec en forme de tache
d'huile en étant très cohérent et je
pense que la nef sûr personne n'est
peut-être pas terminée mais elle
effectivement la série à disperser les
forces cela dit sans la limite il
attaque sur deux fronts ils sont à la
limite de leurs capacités leurs points
forts il est vraiment dans la raison du
zoom etc donc pour le moment je ne s'y
attendait pas et on parlait beaucoup de
personnes ces derniers jours et pas
vraiment justement de ce qui se passait
au nord on s'y attendait pas parce que
on n'avait pas prévu enfin ceux qui
connaissent la capacité à la fois des
conseillers américains anglais
d'aider à concevoir des opérations de ce
niveau des opérations offensives sont
les ukrainiens qu'il en fait ils ont les
ukrainiens qui l'ont conçu dans
l'imaginé pas qui serait capable de la
mener à bien avec intelligence et des
gens se sanglent anglais avec le
renseignement américain bien sûr
l'enquêté le rôle du commandant en chef
de l'armée iranienne valérie el-hallouj
unis parce qu'on dit que c'était lui le
fas stratège derrière eux et sont
reprises et le premier notre pratique de
toute la bande c'est le premier qui a
été formé à l'occidentale je pense le
contrôle de cette autopsie le premier
qui est je veux dire cette habitude
d'être à la fois en liaison avec le
politique est de décliner pour ses
troupes de façon de concevoir les
opérations cet homme est il et c'est un
général occidental en fait donc il est
vraiment aussi alors je peux dire que de
plus d'intelligence non mais je veux
dire chim brigide mais en tout cas quand
on dit que c'est le str
ces cinq jours d'offensive c'est une
galerie rue pelée qu'à travailler mais
celui qui a impulsé qui a donné des
directives qui a concentré ils sont
quinze mille à peu près quelle était sa
stratégie justement si on devait redire
on sait cinq jours bousculés bousculer
les rues de reprendre du territoire
enclencher un processus de victoire la
victoire n'est pas définitive ya pas de
débandade a fire sévère défaite des
russes mais enclencher un processus de
victoire puisque la victoire conduit
toujours à victoire faut pas s'emballer
mais c'est quand même ça quand même
conduit à la victoire et obtenir des
résultats significatifs qui met en
difficulté bien sûr à la fois leur
mairie c'est aussi vous en parliez
peut-être le président poutine jusqu'à
l'hiver justement pour en revenir est ce
que aujourd'hui vladimir poutine est
sous pression à ce qu'elle ait mis en
difficulté
je suis vraiment pas un analyste
politique russe n'est un crime jean au
look mais il semble évident de ce qu'on
voit sur les médias russes étant les
groupes aussi sur les réseaux sociaux de
gens qui soutiennent cette invasion qui
a priori soutiennent les intentions de
vladimir poutine et qui sont maintenant
très très très critique envers la
manière dont celle qu'elle a été
conduite donc il y à beaucoup plus de
critiques envers la les murs poutine
mais aussi envers le commandement de
l'armée russe qu'on peut trouver
maintenant sur les réseaux sociaux et je
pense aussi dans une certaine mesure
même dans les médias d'état russe mais
c'est plutôt elena volochine qui
pourraient le confirmer et les non
justement est-ce que vous pouvez nous
confère on a entendu qu'il y avait des
contestations par exemple aujourd'hui un
certain nombre d'élus à
saint-pétersbourg en l'occurrence qui
commencent à contester effectivement
vladimir poutine oui c'était il ya
quelques jours c'est un groupe de
conseillers municipaux à saint
pétersbourg qui effectivement envoyé une
lettre à la douma d'état aux parlements
d'état pour demander aux députés de
destituer d'intenter une procédure de
destitution de vladimir poutine pour
trahison d'état pour avoir déclenché la
guerre en ukraine et précipité le pays à
sa perte donc ça effectivement ça des
initiatives locales qui sont très
impressionnantes dans le contexte de
répression sans précédent qu'il ya dans
la russie aujourd'hui dans la russie
moderne le fait que les deux camps le
camp de la guerre comme le camp de la
paix sont mécontents de vladimir poutine
et ce depuis un moment déjà ça on le
sait quand même il y a il y à pas mal de
choses qui filtrent là dessus puisque le
camp de la paix bomba et de cette
opinion que vladimir poutine mène le
pays à sa perte et le camp de la guerre
lui prône la guerre totale depuis déjà
un moment disant que si on est
d'ailleurs en ce moment je vais me
dédire puisque tout à l'heure je disais
qu'on ne parlait pas de défaite côté
russe mais il y a un certain nombre de
voix qui sans parler de défaite
puisqu'il ya un tabou et une
classification de la façon dont on doit
s'exprimer en russie mais qui disent
nous devons être solidaires de nos gars
qui sont au front la société doit se
soulever doit se mobiliser pour la
victoire et c'est ça ça veut dire que
oui on est en train de perdre et que à
défaut d'une mobilisation générale de la
population et du passage en économie de
guerre à l'affiché puisque
officieusement la russie aidées a déjà
passé des lois qui permettent à l'eau
ministère de la défense de
réquisitionner n'importe quelle
entreprise à ses fins mais il ne les
fait pas hinse temps alors il le il il
le fait peut-être ponctuellement mais en
tout cas ce n'est pas annoncé
officiellement le passage en économie de
guerre à la mobilisation générale c'est
vraiment un autre niveau ça veut dire
que on pourrait par exemple à instaurer
un système où si vous refusez d'aller au
front vous pouvez aller en prison ça
c'est vraiment la loi martiale donc ça
ça n'a pas encore été instaurée il ya de
plus en plus on entend de plus en plus
de voix en russie aujourd'hui qu'ils
disent à défaut de cela on va juste
perdre la guerre claude blanc présent
oui je crois que l'on a fait ou 6 mai
est soumis à deux critiques opposer les
gens raisonnables et modérés qui
considère cette opération était perdue
d'avancé
ça n'avait aucun sens dès le départ ne
répondait à aucune logique sérieuse et
puis les nazis les ultranationalistes
qui lui disent que il a pas pris les
moyens de ses objectifs et que par
conséquent il faut taper plus fort et
c'est là où vient le risque parce que
ce qu'on croit savoir de poutine c'est
que il est pour le moins décomplexée et
que si un jour il était acculé par
exemple si les ukrainiens arrivé à la
frontière russe ou à la frontière de la
crimée et bien acculé personnellement je
pense qu'il ne se rendrait pas alors
est-ce que son état major est ce que les
services de ces de sécurité sera en
mesure de le déposer de le remplacer je
n'en suis pas si sûr je n'en suis pas si
sûr parce qu'il tient un dispositif et
que tous ces gens ont un intérêt commun
à ce que le système ne saute pas par
conséquent c'est très compliqué comme
comme manoeuvre et
s'ils étaient acculés et si un
remplacement n'était pas envisageable
par les services de sécurité il est
probable qu'ils recoureraient à à
quelque chose qui serait tout à fait
horrible c'est à dire à une arme non
conventionnelles donc vous pensez on
pourrait recourir à l'armé nucléaire
dans ce cas ci les pas à cliquer seul à
le penser ou n'est pas le seul à le
penser
oui d'univers en ukraine j'aimerais bien
j'aimerais bien juste commenté le fait
que en ukraine il n'est pas du tout
passé inaperçu le fait que ses critiques
envers vladimir poutine venant de la
part des nationalistes des pro guerre si
vous voulez se font entendre visiblement
beaucoup plus fort que les voix des
libéraux les antiquaires et beaucoup
d'ukrainiens on tire la conclusion que
bon on voit bien que si on a bien le
courage de critiquer le régime en russie
on peut sans finir en prison et les
excuses des libéraux des opposants à la
guerre
comme quoi ils peuvent pas se faire
entendre parce qu'il risque la prison et
risque des répressions sont pas vraiment
justifiée c'est une situation maintenant
qui alimentent cette rancune que portent
beaucoup beaucoup d'ukrainiens envers
les libéraux russes les soi disant
opposants à vladimir poutine parce que
beaucoup d'ukrainiens leur reproche de
ne pas avoir fait assez et on se demande
si c'est vraiment justifié ses 38 la
peur des ukrainiens aussi en réalité
c'est juste vraiment le cas que les
nationalistes les pro guerre en plus de
libertés en russie pour critiquer le
régime que ceux qui prônent la
démocratie les libéralisations et sont
opposés à la guerre oksana mitrofanova
vous êtes d'accord il ya une rancune du
côté des ukrainiens contre justement ces
libéraux qu'on n'entend pas suffisamment
réussi je pense que plus tôt il faut
poser la question notamment je pense que
en ukraine déjà on a perdu toutes les
illusions et surtout qui en a perdu
l'illusion qui on va avoir ce mouvement
de population à l'intérieur de rossi qui
va peut-être changer l'origine donc on y
craint de ne plus de cet espoir on pense
pas qu'ils auront au régime ont réussi
qui pourrait changer on est dans notre
nombre grâce seulement à l'intérieur de
russie mais je parle bien sûr de
l'avenir proche je ne parle pas de
l'antenne dans l'est dans l'avenir
proche qui va venir on ne pense pas que
ça va venir des seulement deux peuples
oui ce qui va se révolter comme tout par
exemple quand le régime de poutine du
coup voilà pourquoi par exemple le
gouvernement craignant des violences qui
maintenant on insiste que les
négociations avec la russie se trouve
sur le front sur le fond c'est à dire
sur un champ de bataille militaire donc
la négociation c'est ce que ça veut dire
mais la russie ne veut pas d'une
utilisation si on se trouve dans
l'impasse parce que bien sûr l'ukraine
doit récupérer cet électeur et
l'intégrer resterait c'est l'intégrité
territoriale mais y compris la crimée se
sont même souvent dit le maire mais bien
sûr c'est bien sûr et y compris la crue
mais aussi il ya enfin si importante qui
soulignent dans un communiqué les
frontières de 1991 un retour aux
frontières de 800 logements par exemple
récemment il a dit il est dit que pour
beaucoup de russes pour beaucoup de
russes la guerre se trouve très loin
c'est très loin il n'a pas de frappe
donc vraiment à la population russe ne
se sentent pas de chair par la guerre
donc du coup il a dit qu'il faut avoir
c'est un changement sur le flanc par
exemple les frappes contre les
militaires en crimée ça peut faire voir
russe qui a quand même la guerre n'est
pas si long voilà pourquoi c'est l'une
des raisons pourquoi le jeune et demande
aux alliés occidentaux de là où
l'artillerie à longue distance c'est
avoir la capacité aussi frappé un crime
mais il faut comprendre bien sûr ce qui
me frappe en creux même ce sont les
aéroports militaires ou la phrase tout
ce n'est pas par exemple les centrales
électriques ce qui fonde hausse à venir
à l'école de qui est ce que l'indien
pause il a besoin de mobiliser beaucoup
plus l'ensemble de sa population pour
effectivement et gagner cette guerre ou
s'il ne le fait pas est ce qu
effectivement les ukrainiens peuvent
gagner alors je pense que son problème
n'est pas de mobiliser sa population son
problème avoir plus d'un mouvement le
favori alors bien sûr par les mesures
qui ont été omises à des généralisations
général eckhard état de guerre etc pour
le moment il ne peut pas le faire et
quand bien même ils n'ont pas besoin de
le faire non mais quand bien même il le
ferait il est incapable d'augmenter ses
effectifs actuellement on l'a bien vu il
a essayé d'augmenter de quelques
milliers d'hommes les effectifs
actuellement engagés ils n'y arrivent
pas n'y arrive pas parce qu'il n'y a
peut-être pas de ressources palais briau
de les faire venir jusque sur le front
des entraîneurs des équipes et de les
former ça c'est un problème de
logistique ce donc parler mais je veux
dire quand on déclare la mobilisation
générale faut être en mesure de en
mesure de le faire est pour le moment
pas quelque chose qui en une semaine
amènerait 500000 russe soldats sur le
front ukrainien donc cette menace est à
mon avis et est assez faible en revanche
rebondi sur ce que dit la l'ambassadeur
blanchemaison c'est que acculé entre
défauts qu'on appelait les colombes en
face ceux qui ceux qui sont plus
raisonnables dans une situation hyper
pied et où il sent que
lire la situation lui échappe la
probabilité d'utiliser un homme non
conventionnelles clairement une arme
nucléaire elles étaient quasi nulles au
début très très très faible au milieu du
conflit elle est un tout petit peu moins
faible sachant qu'il n'y a pas de
d'armes nucléaires tactiques
tout petit une arme nucléaire c'est une
arme nucléaire et est à ce moment là ont
déclenché un processus et il
déclencherait à mon sens une sorte de
réprobation mondial parce qu'on n'est
pas très loin de là quand même pas très
loin de monde en parlait beaucoup au
début de la guerre d'ailleurs de
l'utilisation possible en cas de la on
était dans le déclaratoire côme d'olt
comme tout le tour tous les bus étaient
déclaratoire et à chaque à chaque moment
où il perdait un tout petit peu pied ont
relancé la machine avec des déclarations
tonitruantes mais qui met là vous pensez
que c'est plus sérieux de l'envisager ce
qu'il faut le regarder sérieusement
comme une probabilité très faible
sachant que moi je pense qu'il
n'utilisera pas mais faut l'envisager il
faut bien voir que les conséquences pour
les pays environnants
commencer par la chine ou d'autres
il ya quand même eu tir mobile quand
même bien qu'une arme nucléaire c'est
pas tout à fait deux centrales
nucléaires
encore un autre sujet que l'arm
l'utilisation de l'armé nucléaire et
dena volochine vous ça vous semble faire
une petite probabilité possible s'il
était acculé derrière poutine si par
exemple la contre-offensive gagné
également personnes
publiques et que ce débat extrêmement
complexe après ma pensé spontanément
la centrale nucléaire de zaporijia c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'on aurait besoin
d'aller utilisé une arme nucléaire alors
que l'on peut faire sauter comme ils
l'ont fait sans doute avec la colonie
penny de ghellinck cas où étaient
détenus les ukrainiens en accusant
ensuite les ukrainiens d'abord tiré un
missile ils ont fait de la centrale
nucléaire de zaporijia une base
militaire c'est à dire que s'il avait
besoin à un moment donné de faire
diversion et en plus d'accuser l'ukraine
pour créer un chaos dans lequel la
défaite russe
changerait de forme et de fond est bien
pourquoi pas faire sauter la centrale
en terme de radioactivité ce qui fait
peur à tout le monde les centrales
nucléaires et d'un tacle sur la centrale
nucléaire déclencherait un processus de
radioactivité lieu de 131 et c'est enfin
tous ces sujets qu'on connaît bien sans
aucune mesure avec une arme nucléaire
qui dont l'effet principal c'est le
blast c'est le l'explosion le deuxième
effet c'est la chaleur le troisième
effet c'est l' impulsion
électromagnétique qui est derrière le
quatrième effet si simplement l'allée du
client valeur la route la radioactivité
donc on a eu notre âge écrasé kiev ses
faux cils hiroshima chez quinze mille
bombes d'une tonne voilà et c'est un
différend de la centrale la centrale
c'est beaucoup plus dangereux pour les
pour le temps c'est beaucoup plus
dangereux la centrale l'univers craag on
a entendu d'ailleurs aujourd'hui le
directeur général de l'aiea raphaël
grossi à dire qu'il y avait des signaux
positifs pour justement qu'il ait des
consultations entre kiev et moscou sur
l'établissement d'une zone de sécurité à
zaporijia c'était le cas aujourd'hui
simple
je ne suis pas au courant de ces
négociations est exactement je pense que
la situation est plus ou moins pareil
qui est vrai clame le départ des forces
russes et les russes ne sont pas prêts à
partir mais au moins on a une situation
où la centrale ne fonctionne plus reste
connecté à l'électricité pour pouvoir
refroidir les réacteurs donc pour le
moment c'est dans une position stable et
aussi d'après mes informations faire une
explosion qui serait en mesure de
provoquer vraiment une grande balle que
de
radioactivité
il faudrait vraiment une très très
grande explosion ce n'est pas exactement
direct les débats petits plats
tchernobyl je pense que les murs sont
quand même assez épais et
bon après on sais pas qu'est-ce que ils
ont peut-être mais comment est-ce que
vous pourrez le faire exploser un sens
d'endommager aussi leurs forces qui sont
là sont présents
faute blanchemaison moi j'ai tendance à
penser qu'il ya en effet une marge de
négociation sur la centrale de prague
alors comme le dit le directeur général
de l'aea parce que jusqu'à présent il
semblait bien que les ukrainiens comme
les russes avaient besoin de cette
électricité et ce avec quoi en faire
alors les ukrainiens à fait normal
puisque c'est leur centrale mais les
russes encore une fois le la primauté de
la crimée et de la pérennisation de la
situation en crimée il faut que
l'électricité une partie de l'écurie
cité au moins viennent de cette centrale
par conséquent on peut imaginer sans
doute une négociation très difficile
mais qui probablement est engagé et le
président macron en a parlé avec poutine
avec vnf qui pour arriver à une solution
de compromis ou en effet le régiment
russe qui est dans cette centrale se
retireraient aux alentours et où il n'y
aurait plus de militaires dans la
centrale mais papa d'ukrainiens non plus
ce qui probablement ne plairait pas à
monsieur hénaff qui est où la centrale
serait placé sous un régime qu'il faut
inventer qu'il faut imaginer de sécurité
internationale qui lui permettrait de
produire de l'électricité et où on
arrêterait de bombarder la centrale
elle-même et les alentours parce que le
territoire de la centrale est très vaste
alors évidemment si un régiment il met
ses ses équipements militaires dont à
côté des réacteurs est évidemment c'est
bombardé de diverses manières donc je
crois que c'est pas tout à fait
impossible c'est peut-être la seule
négociation qui pourrait aboutir mais il
faudrait évidemment à ce moment là que
les choses soient portées au conseil de
sécurité et le veto russe si on peut le
contourner il faut évidemment travailler
avec les chinois aussi qu'ils n'ont en
effet aucun intérêt à ce qu'il ya cet
incident nucléaire comme l'a dit
l'amiral tout à l'heure
et de façon à avoir une centrale qui
continuerait à produire de l'électricité
probablement moyennant la concession
ukrainienne puis de partie de cette
électricité va vers la crimée qui est
probablement ne souhaite pas les
ukrainiens oksana mitrofanova il ya des
négociations en tout cas autour de cette
centrale ça c'est ce qu'a l'air de dire
a fait le gros si un directeur général
de lier les termes parce que le
gouvernement ukrainien parle de zone des
10 militarisation 2010 risation la zone
de sécurité pour l'instant ça ne pas de
connu qu'est ce que c'est comme la
définition des zones de sécurité on peut
poser les questions qu'est ce que c'est
parce que le gouvernement ukrainien
insiste que ce sera un des mythes et les
rosés et je voudrais attirer votre
attention aux sites qui est les
militaires on comprend bien l'odeur
parce que exactement à les quelques
jours le ministre de défense du
plaignant de résine golfe il a parlé
avec son homologue français voilà donc
on a parlé de ce joueur est différente
mais parmi le sujet c'est exactement
centrale impôts déjà et il y a une
petite idée aussi peut-être dit mission
de l'union européenne peut-être mission
de l'union européenne
il ne pas de rossi qui peut bloquer donc
éventuellement l'union européenne peut
appliquer dans cette situation et
surtout la france je pense que emmanuel
mâcon le très bien informé de dangereux
tout simplement parce que c'est la
france sur une pile nucléaire où il ya
plein d ingénieurs qui peuvent très bien
présente et qu'ils sont des risques
quand il ya les militaires dans les
stations nucléaires donc peut-être c'est
exactement la france d'être aussi
peut-être des initiateurs de ce
processus et de leader
amiral à la cool de pee wee d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron s'est impliqué pendant
ces négociations dès le début puisqu'il
a vu le directeur général de l'aiea il
ya quelques semaines donc il ya
effectivement une zone de négociations
autour de cette centrale nucléaire c'est
même peut-être le cas dit l'ambassadeur
c'est même peut-être le seul espace de
négociation possible sur le terrain
militaire sur les hauts dignitaires et
aucun espace de négociation et là de
part et d'autre et c'est normal le
centre assez normal où fut remercié sur
un train de se battre donc elle regarde
y'a pas il n'y a pas de ce n'est pas des
espaces de négociation n'y a pas de
défaite ne tienne petit débandade mais
il n'y a pas de défaite et on les
raisons pas reconnaître une défaite
militaire alors qu'ils ont perdu 3000
kilomètres carrés ici l'impensable
tout petit espace de négociation mais
sous les conditions que vous avez
indiquée c'est à dire la légitime été
donnée par une résolution de l'onu une
seat une surveillance internationale
pour l'en on en est loin mais c'est
normal qu'on a très bien fait d'en
parler d'ailleurs utiles à réagir et de
violences ce qui prouve qu'il avait
touché exactement l'endroit il fallait
toucher c'est le seul petit endroit où
on pourrait espérer commencer à faire un
fil des négociations mais actuellement
le la guerche et la guerre étant que la
guerre n'est pas finie je pense pas que
ce soit possible elena je sais que vous
n'êtes pas dans la tête de vladimir
poutine est détesté que je vous pose
cette question je vous la pose quand
même qu'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant là il ya quand même une vraie
défaite clairement du côté russe on
commence à constater une défaite dans
une bataille maintenant il ya la guerre
est effectivement ce que prévoit en tout
cas
les experts militaires à moscou c'est
que là il y a encore deux trois semaines
de marge de manoeuvre où l'armée
ukrainienne peu avancé avant l'automne
donc cette fameuse raspoutine zaki a
déjà mis les armées en difficulté au
printemps c'est-à-dire au moment de la
fonte des neiges là ça va être les
pluies de tonnes et donc c'est quelque
chose qui rend les opérations militaires
extrêmement difficile donc dans les
prochaines semaines très probablement et
je parle sous votre contrôle sans doute
il y aura encore des combats jusqu'à
jusque jusqu au fait que la ligne de
front se fige pendant un moment jusqu'à
l'hiver et je pense que les russes et
vladimir poutine et c'est ce que
j'entends beaucoup de la propagande
aujourd'hui russe c'est que ils misent
sur le fait que les européens vont geler
en hiver vont amoindrir leur leur
soutien à l'ukraine à cause de la crise
du gaz et que c'est le soutien très
précisément le disais tout à l'heure ce
soutien occidental qui permet
aujourd'hui aux ukrainiens d'abord
l'offensive est de gagner la guerre les
russes experts espèrent un peu vainement
sans doute le fait que les occidentaux
vont amoindrir leur soutien leur soutien
aux ukrainiens à l'aune de l'hiver ce
qui est très peu probable i'm here
alcool d'alfie comment la riposte la
russe qu'elle saura t'elle
contre riposte ou la con tre réponse non
ils ont intérêt à figer la situation
effectivement en attendant leur seul bon
général que le général hiver comme
disait quelqu'un sur un plateau et
attendent une situation dont ils ne
maîtrisent pas donc actuellement est la
seule position pour eux c'est une
position d'attenté les ukrainiens ont
quand même intérêt à gagner encore
pendant le temps qui leur reste des
impôts du territoire parce que
finalement ce sont des conquêtes de
territoires ils l'ont fait
intelligemment et je sais pas si vous
l'avez dit avant on arrivait ils l'ont
fait en étant inspiré aidé par le
renseignement américain
d'autres sources de renseignement aidé
par la façon dont on apprend à commander
les opérations dans le monde donc
occidentale c'est à dire en liaison avec
le pouvoir politique en déclinant vers
le terrain les objectifs qui sont
approuvés de part et d'autre et en
laissant la part grande à l'initiative
c'est le contraire de ce qui se passe en
russie donc pour le moment je pense que
les ukrainiens vont commencer à enfin
continué pardon essayer d'enfoncer le
clou les russes vont essayer de
procrastiner aux fins de et ce qui était
intéressant quand je suis arrivé on
parlait de carson c'était sans doute pas
c'était sans doute un objectif de
diversion au départ et jade vient
peut-être un objectif réel devant la
faiblesse de l'armée russe ont quant à
elles attribuées c'est bien sûr un autre
sujet oksana mitrofanova
comment voyez vous les prochaines
semaines donc dans le jours à venir je
répète aussi par exemple à la demande de
leurs clients de ce civil tout
simplement maintenant il est très
prudent parce que la russie pour ses
ventes chez tout simplement bombarder
les infrastructures dont on dit qu'il le
faisait ce matin
il se faisait il 40 et on va faire bien
sûr les bombardements dans leur
structure donc du coup je comprendre que
les opinions sont très fatigués de la
sirène de france un terrien mais l'omc
l'union répète qu'il ne faut pas
négliger ces signaux au moins il faut
essayer de se protéger parce qu'on
bombarde l'infrastructure militaire
exemple on a eu récemment des personnes
qui est spécialiste d'électricité quand
on a essayé de réparer les centrales qui
était bombardée donc du coup je pense
que le gouvernant le gouvernement
ukrainien maintenant a aussi une double
tâche s est essayé de réfléchir comment
on peut et protéger cette infrastructure
de la production de lait et
d'électricité
moi aussi il faut le réparer tout
simplement s'être essoufflée structures
il faut voir les outils pour réparer par
exemple il faut réfléchir aussi à l'aide
de l'occident qui viennent avec les
matériaux pour réparer cette
infrastructure qui se continue en
sachant que c'est l'hiver qui arrive
ensuite sur le ferons nous si ce qui
était très important de ne pas parler
des villes de confiance quand même ce
qu'est ce qui est essentielle si c'était
exactement la ville de coutances tout
simplement parce que commencer il ya le
réseau de chemin de fer et comme s'ils
trouvent le réseau de chemin de fer la
logistique russe le provisionnement
s'est passé exactement par cette ville
d'occupants ce donc la prise de courant
ce parlement ukrainien assez social aux
pattes de vie millénaire elle est
fondamentale militaire
lisier sont également essentiels merci
beaucoup à sa mamie train mitrofanova
d'avoir été avec nous merci lna à
volochine merci
miral un col delle fille mercy toute
blanche maison merci à julie leur tract
d'abord être avec nos directs de kiev
merci à vous tous de dire s'il y est
[Musique]